one of the hardest I've ever laughed on
the show is this guy and the editors are
hilarious because they didn't have to do
this this guy is a very serious show and
he's like crying he's like I just want
to go home he goes and I busted up
laughing so hard Lizzy Anderson decided
to leave the farm after this guy's
saying I want to go home yeah he didn't
have to do that bro it was just the
exclamation point on the statement you
have to like I want to go home my boy
I'm gonna put you on my sex swing quiet
moon cakes
two
one welcome everybody to another episode
of The Genius brain podcast this is
definitely like the porn where they have
a huge penis in their face and they have
to feel around for it and they're
pretend like they don't know what it is
yeah these popsicles warm yeah what kind
of porn category is that yeah let me
tell you something porn is a little too
crazy for me now and I don't like it as
much yeah there's a lot of uh weird uh
incest stuff that's popping up a lot of
it what the [ __ ] too much of it why why
don't need the storyline and they always
say like Mommy and [ __ ] like don't say
Mommy
say Mom or Dad yeah let's not use all
that stuff
even like in non-non incest porn
whenever I hear Daddy I'm like that
either Papi Papi's cool
that's weird dude yeah all of it is not
okay I think patriarch of the home
please you think that's a red flag if
you're making love and sweet coitus to
somebody and they start calling you do
you like um what do we call it sexy talk
no silent dude just quiet it just no
talking unless you're [ __ ] weird are
you like silence
just heavy breathing no she don't mind
bro looks at me straight she doesn't no
facial says hurry up
hurry up
give me two seconds babe
not silent but like you know I just
don't like the talking you don't be do
you do you be like ah
I try to keep that [ __ ] I try to keep
that [ __ ] under wrapped you know why
because I feel like if I'm if we're
gonna get real for a sec if I moan I
feel like that's be you being a [ __ ]
like yeah no man you got girls like me
everybody
feel that girl you know I don't have to
feel nothing then we have a woman Robin
couch
having uh consensual coitus consensus
C Double C do you like it when a guy
moans when you're doing something very
special for him yeah it's a nice
confirmation that like I'm doing the
right stuff yeah see I told you you
idiot yeah wouldn't it be a matter if no
if they make no noise if they're just
like breathing through their nose like
I don't do that a little off-putting
because I can't breathe out of my nose
let's just say Robin let's say like you
are putting on your best moves and the
guy is just dead silent I feel like that
would [ __ ] with your with your you know
self-confidence yeah I just think it
would just make me feel awkward like it
would feel like an episode of the office
or something yeah
is though too with lovemaking I think
it's whatever you do whatever it is that
makes you tick you gotta do you know
what I mean like if that makes sense
like whatever that you like you have to
conceive
no no it can't be like disingenuous you
know what I mean like yeah you don't
want to you don't want someone to do
some [ __ ] that they don't like yeah just
sound like chewbots
I'm like that's weird this feels forced
you know that's what it is when I was
younger I didn't I didn't I would make
less noise but it was because I was
insecure about like being looking or
sounding weird now I don't care okay
I'll be like
no I just you just [ __ ] make whatever
like now you just gotta let it out I
just go Japanese baby
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] whatever dude I hate Japanese
porn with everything that I have oh it's
like that's weird it sounds repay it's
not for us okay also why pixelation why
yeah and then you're cool with like
octopuses
uh that was the uh workaround for
pornography for I think like drawing I
saw this documentary about a guy who
started the tentacle porn genre that
guys so that was the way to get around
um censoring stuff because it's not a
penis so if you use a tentacle it was
different so that was the loophole
around it and that's how it got what was
the idea behind the pixelation of the
dick I don't understand because they
thought it was gay or is it like like
I'm trying to really understand like why
did they do that like did they think it
was like home like like homosexual to
see a guy's dick is just like homophobia
what is it don't they also blur the
vagina too why does Japanese porn
pixelate uh genitalia but they don't
really do they pixelate the girl too
but a majority of this stuff is censored
I'll look it up but if I
go to a funeral and be like the last
thing she was watching was Japanese porn
talk to me about cheerleading so this is
my birthday I got her back got her back
after post death yeah but I remember
like
just back in the day when you know
you'll be trying to look up some Asian
porn and all these Japanese stuff would
pop up and I'm like why what is going on
with their teeth how come none of it's
straight teeth
I don't understand because Korean people
have very straight teeth Japanese people
don't have straight teeth they got a lot
of these pornos but let me tell you
something when a Japanese girl bites
into an apple you know who it's from
they're just fine though huh I'll say
that the girls are bomb but it's just
weird scenarios it'll be like Subway and
like it's like it's always like
regrouping
had me dying laughing was because there
was this lady who was in an English she
was an English teacher no no she was
trying to learn how to speak English and
they were doing it by [ __ ] there it
is so there was a that's a good story
I'm a foreign teacher and he's like he's
not even uh American himself like he's
like Italian or something so he would
just sit there and she goes untrust uh
laughing but she's really hot that's one
way to learn English man I know it's
effective you can't forget that you will
remember how to say ball the the best
line of that porno was when uh after he
nuts in her face she looks at it and
then she goes oh Japanese a style
no way she's so sucking the nut off of
his dick but it's like why did you see
me
oh yes a Japanese a style yeah because
the Japanese did coin that term [ __ ]
right I I literally well [ __ ] is also
a dish it's a [ __ ] udon what the hell
is that I think it means like everything
or everywhere or something like that oh
is that what [ __ ] means yeah it's like
everything bagel all the time can I get
the [ __ ] Bagel please yeah you want it
tonight or later I hate to interrupt
this poetry oh yeah
thank god let's go Robin couch what we
got so grabbing couch Japanese adult
videos are still censored due to article
175 of the Japanese criminal code which
prohibits the sale and distribution of
obscene materials most mainstream
production companies belong to ethical
associations that determine what's
acceptable to show similar to what
America passed in the 30s to the 60s
well America has one of those so the
loopholes so they can show people having
sex but not with people you just cannot
specifically see the genitals but you
can still see what's going on it's like
kind of blurred but you and you see like
you see like Bush yeah they barely
pixelated
we know what's going on here you're not
fooling anybody it's very obvious what's
happening do you remember the first time
you guys ever saw uh
pornography I remember the first time I
seen it it was at my buddy's house he
was an Indian kid he was sick and we
went to his house okay
and he was like a little like he would
download everything off like LimeWire
there it is and it was um and it was
somebody it was somebody having sex with
someone's mom it was like it was like a
MILF thing milfy and I remember watching
it and as we watched it I was like I
can't believe like because I didn't
understand the concept of pornography
and I was like I had so many questions
and I had one of my questions was who's
filming this right I was like how does
this stop that when they first watched I
swear to God what a loser he's like well
uh what kind of lens are they using yeah
who's the gaffer here Hey where's the
cell guy it wasn't even that under it
wasn't even that it was more about like
I was like I can't believe this
[ __ ] is having sex with
someone's mom like that's crazy that's
the mother like I thought that was like
real [ __ ] like I remember the Milf
Hunter site I used to be like I used to
release it was a website dude
are the decibels correct on this right
here because I think the audio is
they were all right they wouldn't make
it making fun of here Mr technical porn
guy his name is technical it was just
like I just didn't understand like
questions yeah because I was like
nobody's in porn and starts worrying
about those type of things they just go
whoa look at these titties no for sure
first thing you thought was my dad does
sound dead I I'm not sure if uh I don't
sound like Kermit the Frog well Miss
Piggy doesn't do that for me
I just remember thinking like I said so
many questions like I can't believe I
because I thought that [ __ ] was real I
was like this is nuts it is real you
know but I just didn't understand I was
like this is crazy someone's mom having
sex with like someone from Rando I was
probably in like
fifth grade sixth grade oh wow oh I
think I was younger than you I was third
grade when I first saw it on 56k you
think you're better than me bro because
you were younger I'm way better than you
yeah and I said this to you multiple
times not for that reason but yeah okay
but it was like on a 56k modem and I
just remembered just like waiting
forever for this [ __ ] picture to
upload and it was this blonde lady with
huge Dairy Queens
look at those things and I just was
amazed that I told my friend to print it
out for me on a piece of paper nice and
he did and I just folded it up real nice
and tight and I hit it in my pocket and
I was and I ran back into my house my
mom's like where'd you go nowhere
did you have fun at Sam's house shut the
[ __ ] up Mom now what was your first like
pornographic like video you've seen I
don't remember the first video but I
just remember the first time I ever saw
porn was on that computer at his house
in his parents bedroom and we just saw
it go
slowly [ __ ] load and I was amazed but
I do remember I didn't like watching
mail on women porn I we watched women on
women because seeing another penis would
like would creep me the [ __ ] out yeah
like I for some reason I couldn't switch
off the fact that that was somebody
else's because you did me and my friends
I was gonna say me and my friends in
Middle School uh we would because we
would watch porn together which is kind
of weird but it's because we're kids
right so boys watch this boys watch porn
together and we would we would cover the
dude's dick and be like ew like yeah
like because we thought it was like yeah
there's that one friend that was like
don't cover it I need it let it be we're
so concerned with like not seeming gay
in front of our friends but then the
camera angle would change and then your
the dick would be over here and then
you'd like yes you're playing
whack-a-mole with this dude's dick
essentially is what you're doing a lot
of people don't understand too it's like
as you get older when you're like more
and more like comfortable with your
sexuality you tend to do more
quote-unquote like gay things because
you don't care it doesn't matter it is
what it is it is what it is I remember
when I first came to La I had a buddy of
mine
yeah he was at least one I mean he's
he's pretty like flaming right and he
was a musician at the time and one of
our clear signs was that number one he
would only cover Adele songs and I'm
like you might be a little gay something
going on slide number two the guy was
flaming as [ __ ] right but I think
because he was so hyper religious he
didn't want to come out but
um I didn't know that he wasn't out
because he clearly was I mean to us we
thought he was like openly gay and we
were going karaoke and I'll and I asked
him I was like hey dude how long have
you been gay or when did you find out
and when did you come out just trying to
have a hard heart with them right
because we've been friends for quite a
minute he goes [ __ ] I'm not gay looked
at him and I'm drunk at this time right
I was like boy you gay I was like David
quit [ __ ] around he goes I'm not
[ __ ] gay I'm like
you're gay bro
don't [ __ ] lie to me I was getting a
little interviews like you think I'm
stupid I was like come on you're gay he
goes I [ __ ] love [ __ ] I'm like that
is the gayest thing I've ever heard in
my life yeah there's no straight man
that says that and he was like looking
at me I was like am I on like a hidden
camera show you forced him out of the
closet and so I had to ask friends he
goes
you know he's gay right and there goes
like yeah he's gay he's like no he says
he's not gay and so after that everybody
was super confused because we just
assumed he was and so we're just like
okay if he's not he's not lo and behold
your later comes out to us yeah he goes
I'm gay I was like I you got mad at me
[ __ ]
yeah like I knew you were dude yeah
[ __ ] singing Adele everywhere like oh
God damn it I knew this just wasn't
ready yeah but he uh he came out and
then what I found out was it was because
you for some reason so scared like his
mom was hearing him all the time and I'm
like bro you you're with friends we all
knew right you just flaming up the whole
place you touch the wall the whole
building would go down and his mom
probably knows too oh his mom knew yeah
of course right because she raised him
right yeah and so I guess he told me
that when he came out to his mom and was
like it was Korean he goes I know I
don't know I know he was gay
okay
I used to call homo
don't worry about it
let's get into uh the news section that
I only do with these [ __ ] it's
going to be the section called Twitter
you wild Twitter does something pop up
actually I don't even know I just made
that up right now I like it but Twitter
you're crazy
Robin casting the internet bruh I just
thought that this [ __ ] was [ __ ]
hilarious to me I was high as [ __ ] the
other night saw this [ __ ]
you'd be partaking in marijuana
sometimes let me tell you this the
internet bruh me it's okay boo [ __ ]
farts are natural her but you freestyle
to it me [ __ ] was fire fire
dude meme culture has been some one of
the best things that has ever happened
to the internet oh yeah that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] hilarious I feel like that's the
same dude from the from the voicemail
you guys ever remember the first time
you heard a queef in real life it wasn't
phased bruh yeah I wasn't I I did and I
I kind of love I still laugh yeah and we
laugh I just I just have you ever made a
girl feel ashamed though no
I wasn't no that sounds like a lie right
there no when the voice goes
high-pitched that's a lie how are you
gonna feel how are you gonna be like hey
[ __ ] farter
what's up got old duck [ __ ] [ __ ]
quacking away huh no I always thought it
was kind of I've always just laughed
like I was just laughing and they
laughed and then I didn't know what a
queef was until I first heard it I was
like oh really where did that noise come
from and I just remember the labia is
going and I was like that's exactly what
happens that's exactly what happened I
pulled out and then it the [ __ ] farted
and I was like I had no idea yeah I was
shocked you're like wow I wasn't flat I
just didn't know that that could happen
and it blew my [ __ ] mind and then my
friends made fun of me because you don't
know what a queef is dude [ __ ] virgin
I was like yeah I was a virgin dude
that's the point I literally just had
sex yes and I didn't know that it was it
happens a lot when you do a dog a style
dog a dog a is that is this true Patrick
in your in your studies and you're fine
I think for me it's when you go like if
you go all the way out and then back in
and all the way out back in you kind of
create an air building this is the
scientific area
it's kind of like did you ever have a
not silly putty but there was like a
yeah like it was like yeah Silly Putty
would do that [ __ ] and you like put your
thumb in in and out and especially start
farting that's a queen
you know what I mean it's the air pocket
baby it's physics stuff that's just air
baby I wonder what that feels like for a
woman
can we is it relaxing yeah what I wish
somebody could tell us what this feels
like you are comfortable yeah
you know and this is purely like we are
curious I apologize for what we're
putting and you're putting us through an
open dialogue and that's what's
important I have a couple of questions
number one just letter answers when you
first uh quaffade Cafe right and then
also too what does it feel like also
three on a scale from one to ten how
much do you hate us
start with that one first
time
accurate once I just talk like
this
yeah
I I mean it was kind of embarrassing I
remember the first time it was a little
bit embarrassing
um but then like laughing It Off made it
better um
as I don't like have that distinct of an
idea of like that consciously what it
feels like so
I don't I think you're more just like
shocked by the sudden fart noise okay
like thinking about actually what
physical Sensations you're experiencing
so it's overpowering it's just like
startling or like I feel like it's also
like when like two like chests rub and
make a fart noise too sometimes like
that's fire it's just like it's kind of
like forget about what exactly happened
and you start laughing at the fart noise
fart noises are funny man
you have to laugh at them otherwise like
what's the point exactly you have to I
remember specifically Miss gilkinson in
elementary school got mad at me because
I couldn't stop laughing at this kid
that farted in class I was in tears wow
funny and she looks at me she goes you
know David as you get older these
Natural Body reactions aren't going to
be as funny and you lied because it's 10
times funny as you're older it's way
funnier bro if you're at a business
meeting like just say like it's like a c
like a corporation like everyone's got
suits on long table like this everyone's
like okay quarterly reports or you know
X Y and Z we're picking up sales here we
need to work on marketing here and then
you just hear
in the middle of that dying laughing I'm
gonna die live this is meaning over this
fool literally showed me this show yeah
called alone right and remember I was I
had coven that show was fire I had
coveted for seven days I watched like
three or four seasons of it this show is
the craziest show I've ever seen in my
life
first of all number one the reason why
it's like State the way people describe
the show to me they told me that these
are like the top Wilderness experts they
are absolutely not because in the later
Seasons there Naked and Afraid has these
people but they only have two [ __ ]
items and they're [ __ ] butt naked and
they last way longer than some of these
people some of them yeah right now not
to say that these people aren't dope but
they actually have all their tools with
them they have flints they have whatever
and just to go back to the farting thing
full circle one of the hardest I've ever
laughed on the show is this guy and the
editors are hilarious because they
didn't have to do this this guy is a
very serious show and he's like crying
he's like I just want to go home and he
goes and I busted up laughing so hard
yeah who is the Ender that decided to
leave the park after this guy's saying I
want to go home yeah he didn't have to
do that yeah bro it was just the
exclamation point on the statement you
have to think I wanna go home you know
what I mean like he's in bad shape like
these desperations of the show is that
these people stay out there till the
last person falls so you could be out
there for a year you don't [ __ ] know
whoa and after a while like they start
to lose time they're like I've been out
here for maybe three or four months I
don't [ __ ] know and they start
talking about their family and [ __ ]
that's when it gets real sad
and it's legit it's their [ __ ]
completely by themselves on Naked and
Afraid they got a camera guy they got
food on nakedness
with [ __ ] ants crawling up their
vaginas and penis holes yeah for a
little bit but I feel like afterwards
they put on some clothes yeah dude
they're fine
so there was a girl who uh she was
labeled as a crazy person on the show
sure and uh she started writing blogs
about how it was like they do have a
camera crew there that you get to see
every now and then and she said that
some of the contestants would like try
to steal some like the granola bars from
like it's cameraman sure but they don't
help them out they're not supposed to so
they'll if they do do it it's because
they're breaking the [ __ ] rules yeah
but they're it's legit they're butt
naked out there and they're [ __ ]
suffering dude there's an Arctic version
now they're like in the snow dude alone
you would die alone is so for real you
would die but I want to watch that
episode watch alone alone is alone on
fire Bro Dog the best part is when they
just start singing to themselves because
they have no music so they have to
create it themselves I do that now that
makes sense
that was a guy the white there's a white
dude that was super Rasta so he had
dreads of course okay right and then out
of nowhere he's quiet he goes
reggaeton
nobody there yeah and he's just losing
his mind yeah
and he's just quiet for another like 30
seconds he just misses those drums do
that at work I'll just be walking around
just saying crazy [ __ ] like singing to
my I do that now what's your song that
you'd be singing I don't know it just
depends on whatever's in my head yeah
yeah I'll just I'll say crazy [ __ ] all
that I do that all the time I probably
am a little crazy but I do that [ __ ] all
the time so in the woods I would be
[ __ ] how long do you think you guys
would survive
I think I could give myself [ __ ] 20
days tops
impressive those [ __ ] out there
for like six months three days no water
you know in like every season like four
people drop down in like the first week
oh yeah every time let's see the first
week four or three people jump out
you're giving yourself I don't give you
20 days
trained for if I had the skills to be
able to do it can you make a fire with
the sticker
I would get [ __ ] up on the house
building part like a lot I'll be trying
to build my house and it falls on me and
I'll be like I get frustrated and I'll
probably want to leave that's what it
would be for like the first two days
over just stupid mistakes there was a
person who put his uh Flintstone on his
jacket and then he lifted his jacket and
this one still rolled into the water and
so he had to leave because he couldn't
create fire anymore if I don't have fire
I'm done so he called it in is the other
girl could call she had a piece of wood
she's talking to the camera she goes you
know I've been out here she missed the
wood and she hit her head and split her
hand open so she had to leave wow so
these little small mistakes and you're
[ __ ] and some of them are like they're
playing the body fat game so like some
dudes will get like 300 pounds and then
go on the island so then if they can't
find food then they'll just kind of eat
themselves they're like a bear exactly
exactly and then some people are just
trying to outlast like three other
people and like what will happen is one
person will be like they'll do medical
checks and they'll say oh dude you're
too skinny you can see your ribs and
then they'll take you out and they'll
pull you from the show
I would want the the that do you ever
see Hunger Games when they put the
little spout into the tree and the water
comes out like I wonder if that really I
would get one of those that should work
it should not work Pez looks the dumbest
[ __ ] thing I've ever heard on this
show dude
I was like is that legit [ __ ]
Elementary
like in the Amazon where they have
jungle vines where you you know when you
see the moves when they cut it and water
comes out that's real okay
money don't grow long
this figure looked amazing I was like I
would bring one of those on on Naked and
Afraid if that existed but I wasn't sure
I did obviously didn't do the research
but people believe in everything can we
fact check that Robin
I'm so embarrassed
now oh [ __ ] she's doing it's the water
spout from Hunger Games work the water
spout from as he says Patrick's an idiot
I'm just gonna say no search results
purification systems they have nowadays
like they're you still have to do a lot
of work to get like clean water oh for
sure and sometimes they have to risk it
there's a person who decided that he
wanted to drink uh through this specific
type of moss and this Moss actually has
iodine in it and if you guys don't know
iodine kills a lot of bacteria that's
you know in water and so people who have
like survival packs they'll have iodine
packs and it's that it's that [ __ ]
orangey reddish you know amber color
they'll throw it in there gets rid of
the bacteria it tastes like [ __ ] but
you're fine so he assumed that the Moss
had enough iodine but it doesn't drank
it got [ __ ] poisoning the parasites
in his gut had a leaf damn
a little bit
[Music]
you don't have to it doesn't exist and
Pat's an idiot yeah we just wanted a
definitive answer look like
like on outdoorlife.com a survival
skills thing is like how to get water
and syrup from trees and it looks like
they nailed something into a tree and I
do know you can pull syrup from trees
that way or sap because yes you can get
you could do that with maple syrup 100
maple butter baby
it does say Patrick's an idiot
possible that's why I said I can dig a
Little Deeper yeah I think we need more
research done I think we don't need
research Robin you're going to be tired
you'll be here all night
we actually came out like Sparkletts
water in America
is like you know baby just go to that
spike a hole no water
I'm gonna go to the park tonight and try
it out yeah bro what the jungle vines do
have it because it'll store it it's
Hollow and it'll store the water in
there and you chop it off and you could
drink some water that's amazing yeah so
I actually looked that up because I saw
it uh you know in movies and stuff and
then yeah there's so many unknowns being
in the wild like we we're so unprepared
like even the Moss like thinking like I
would have no idea that Moss had any
form of iodine in it at all yeah uh but
think about so many of those little
things about the nature that we are
completely unprepared portion of me
losing weight that helped me like work
with food was watching naked and afraid
because they would actually put in like
the amount of like caloric intake a
human needs to survive and I was
thinking to myself explain it very well
they do it very very well the thing to
myself is like oh I'm not actually
hungry like I think I'm [ __ ] hungry
but I had six burritos today
they're actually starving so when they
say they're starving they're [ __ ]
starving yeah and like the amount of
food that they have to gather to keep
their body just alive damn you know just
to maintain their like not even maintain
their weight just so they don't lose
like survive three pounds that day is
like crazy and how they have to
um plan out what the activity they're
gonna do for that day because it's like
if I do too long of an activity I'm
gonna burn up all my calories and I'll
be starving damn you know what I was
wondering for ladies because they had
their menstruation Cycles no that just
stops bro let's just stop oh when you're
when you're starving [ __ ] huh oh this
man knows about women dude oh yeah don't
quote me on that but that's just stop it
doesn't really it's called the Amarillo
when your body fat dips too low there it
is see and then my dick stop working
there it is I know what's up that's why
you're eating six burritos that's why I
thought I didn't notice that fact but I
was like yeah Dave's eating a lot of
burritos I was going
at my [ __ ] fattest right so I had to
try I track my food just to see how much
I was eating first of all it was hyper
irregular some days it would be like a
thousand calories but on the average
days that I was eating I was eating an
average to 3 300 to like 4 000 calories
wow I had no [ __ ] idea because you're
just eating yeah going about your day
and every time somebody has a grazer for
sure oh I'd be I'm not only a grazer I'm
a farmy eater I feel like Farm boys
where they had that big breakfast
because they need to work the whole day
yeah well I would have that breakfast
and then lay down you have a lumberjack
slam slam bag that's my favorite moves
over Miami I had a MyFitnessPal that got
I don't know it's gone now I don't know
what the password of [ __ ] is for it but
I specifically remember this day because
I I would eat this every day I would eat
at Avenue 26 tacos fine right I would
eat 10 tacos at night 10 talk damn right
that's enough no shaming all right
no it's not 10 bottles of water that's a
lot of water chips
yeah that's not bad yeah yeah you stupid
idiot aren't you a [ __ ] diet person
dummy but that's a lot of calories
200 calories right there yeah there's a
lot of tacos probably like 10 Avenue
toys this is just at night but in the
morning I'll get like take out like
Chinese food or some [ __ ] right then
I'll get like dim sum and then I get
like some pizza in between sounds good
it sounds like a dream bro right and so
I'm I'm just eating like it's like it's
nothing and then when I calculated
roughly the calories it was like 3 200
to 4 000 something calories a day and
I'm like how the [ __ ] am I still hungry
wow
why do I still want to eat and just for
reference what how many calories are you
supposed to eat in a day like for you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
for me right now I'm eating about 2200
but he's also like 280 pounds yeah back
then you would you were like three
something I was like okay let's relax
282.90 all right oh my bad you're like
three right you hit the 800 Market yeah
47 000 pounds fatties
I honestly I generally thought you were
at like 300 for a while not man it's
because I got muscles no I was out but
you look great I was I was a big [ __ ]
boy [ __ ] dude hey man I'm trying to get
jacked and ripped though dude I'm trying
to look like Pat you're on your way man
look at Pat bro some of the guns bro is
that where the cameras are that's where
the camera
yeah dude [ __ ] and the lighting bro
come on Doug let's go look at that you
look like a Greek statue dude when you
did that [ __ ] sorry Robin
Robin's like I actually like fat Korean
guys yeah
sorry yeah I know Robin's type dude yeah
Robin what's your type a fat cream with
low self-esteem if you have one do you
have a type I I don't I don't know I I'm
in one of those phases where I I most
men I meet I feel are stupid all right
top three yeah you're right though so
you're saying I'm your type thank you
three times top three top three top
three
top three what types just of men that
you tend to enjoy
to
enjoyed
I tend to enjoy it yeah bro bring them
back to my cave yeah you [ __ ] eat
their heads so
I really I I don't like are we speaking
just like physical traits because I'm
more of like a person like a personality
person both let's get a little bit of
both a little bit of physical traits a
little bit of the other stuff I mean I
need like someone to be funny
it's good yeah that's always a must
and you gotta have jokes situationally
aware and empathetic of like the people
around them
[Music]
just kidding no that's very important
how big do the eyes need to be yeah you
do a single eyelid or double eyelid
no eyelids very cool there we go I want
okay no I don't know that's a hard
question because I just like you're more
of a vibeye person you need to feel them
out first you need the Vibes most of the
guys I've dated like more than like just
a couple dates I remember when I first
met them I didn't think oh I'm attracted
to this person but then I started to
talk to them and I was like oh I am very
attracted to this that's what every girl
has said to me dude I saw your face
disgusting now that you talk a little
bit annoying not only is that what I
said David that's what you said first of
all that's what you said okay you know
what you're turning me on right now
Robin so yeah I like it when women yell
at me so yeah yeah in your face yeah
hopefully later tonight in your face
Robin I should have never shared these
things
you're going to cry myself to sleep
tonight
[Laughter]
let's go
Twitter you wild
I call this
the whitest grits uh raw shrimp so watch
this [ __ ]
Frozen strip straight into the water for
the people who are listening why she do
that
takes his grits
looks soupy and watery as [ __ ] no
seasoning whatsoever puts it on a
[ __ ] disposable plate yeah it's gonna
burn right through there as soon as you
see the Disposable Place
in Water that's how she cooked them
that's how she cooked them that's it
shrimp and water with the shells on
that's not right that looks terrible ew
eats it puts it in her mouth she goes
she goes mmm it tastes like [ __ ] she
goes that is really good [ __ ]
disgusting dude have you seen like you
know those Uncle Roger videos that
everyone's like talking about like
everyone's like those are pretty hyped
like him oh yeah yeah but the way these
people I don't know how he finds his
original Source content but like how
they make their rice how they do
everything it's like it is the worst
it's like it's like almost how not to
cook actually sure it's terrible you
know what the wildest thing is there's
the internet yeah you could look this up
yeah just go on YouTube
so many [ __ ] recipes for shrimp and
grits and they're all pretty [ __ ]
decent and it's really easy too chicken
grits is like not that hard to make yeah
it's really [ __ ] easy first of all do
you know what this reminds me of so I
did a show on Netflix called the best
leftovers ever right I'm a Netflix star
and so yeah you are yeah
it's coming back oh I hope a lot of
people have been asking for it oh
telling you the fans are real either way
there was a person on the show when I
was on there that [ __ ] actually made
me eat something where I gagged so this
person easiest challenge ever it was
breakfast you could make anything into
breakfast even if you want the the most
simple route and you got docked points
for it at least it tasted good right and
that could be your forgiving Grace sure
so this lady Sweet Lady by the way
decides that she wants to poach eggs
she's never poached eggs before oh yeah
right there's many different ways to
poach eggs there's a learning curve to
it though yeah simple way to do it get
that water hot swirl it create a Vortex
it'll encase it in something very
[ __ ] nice she's never poached eggs
before takes it out way too early it's
still gelatinous with the egg whites egg
is still cold doesn't get a slotted
spoon gets a regular spoon just like
that takes that potion liquid which is
just water water and then dumps it onto
her dish because I had to [ __ ] eat
that oh my God so I get a we had this
little earpiece in our ear and two of
the other judges didn't want to eat it
and they go David you're up to bat and I
was like you got to do this and I I hear
it and then like as I'm about to eat it
okay okay let's cut David can you undo
your face because my face is like this
because he knew you're about to get
stamina but I knew I was gonna eat the
[ __ ] I'm gonna eat it and they go okay I
know this is really hard but can you say
something nice about it I go you
finished I just just go away because it
was that bad and that's what that [ __ ]
reminds me of oh my God one of the
funniest comments I read on that thing
was like how how the [ __ ] do you guys
invade countries for spices and then
never use it
that's funny because they're [ __ ]
these guys dude the way she cooked it
was like she was [ __ ] Yan can't cook
like she knew exactly what she was doing
she's killing it she was coughing in her
head this is really not a single spice
by the way water no salt no even salt no
butter no butter because you're supposed
to yeah saute it a little bit right
maybe butter
at least plain as [ __ ] like just eating
a shrimp just boiled Frozen she's eating
oatmeal and [ __ ] shrimp she's like
this is [ __ ] good dog
let me tell you something I know like
this is like ongoing online joke that
white people can't cook it's true though
not not true it's true all right all
right there's like a very specific sect
of white people which I can't cook huh
like who
Trail trash book dude yes southern food
like like New Orleans Cajun but there's
I mean it's not all white yeah
but the funny thing about the original
too is like even people too who think
that they can cook they can't really
cook like I remember just watching these
videos where they would like uh like we
would watch like people who cook right
and they just kind of throw a bunch of
like seasoning I'm like that looks way
too [ __ ] salty because you don't know
how to season your food I was like no no
that's way too [ __ ] salty you don't
know what you're doing like just because
you put onion powder and [ __ ] garlic
salt and everything doesn't mean it's
gonna taste good your [ __ ] all taste the
[ __ ] same yeah there was a video that
went uh not viral but like on Twitter
was pretty big but there was a girl who
was like a home chef and she was cooking
some [ __ ] up and then she made a
sarsooka like it's like I mispronounced
like tomato sauce and eggs yeah it's
like a it's a Moroccan dish I've had it
quite a few times so it's pretty good
and then you know like black Twitter was
ripping up this girl look at your
unseasoned ass white food I was like
that's from [ __ ] like West Africa bro
yeah like that's not white people food
yeah but even then people don't know
that [ __ ] but black Twitter was ripping
reps you can't season your I was like
that's a [ __ ] Moroccan dish dude the
[ __ ] are you talking about that has
hella spices in it yeah but people don't
know because they only see oh I don't
where's the [ __ ] Sasson where's the
[ __ ] garlic salt that's all you
[ __ ] know
exactly so when they look at a West
africanist they call it a white dish I'm
like that's not that's not white and
she's a professional chef that's [ __ ]
hella good wow I just I don't know man
food's [ __ ] weird cooking is the [ __ ]
man cooking really is hey what's your
favorite dish sourdough [ __ ] well this
is all the podcast I was making
sourdough I'm like dog I lost so much
respect for him dude I made Saturday
this [ __ ] was amazing
because the [ __ ] the thing they don't
tell you is that the [ __ ] goes old in
three hours dude when you bake [ __ ]
fresh it goes It goes literally gets
rock hard within 30 minutes yeah like
you're making it wrong dude actually I
don't know I've never I can't pick
because it's too hard you have like two
honestly one day and it's hard as [ __ ]
but it was good it's like fiori like
Fury bread it's like it has that that
softness in the beginning it's amazing
why'd you start making sourdough dude
because it was a pandemic and then my
buddy I didn't know it was a fad but my
buddy Thomas was like Hey I want to make
bread and I was like gonna [ __ ] make
bread that's sick he's like yeah like
just do this it's gonna feed the yeast
and then I did I did it and I was like
oh this is cool pandemic bored yeah I
was like all right that's just kind of
fire though and then I was like we're
doing this all the time I told myself I
was like I'm not gonna buy bread anymore
but then I was like it's way too much
[ __ ] work dude baking is hella
[ __ ] it's hard you know I've seen
people it's hard there's this one guy on
YouTube who's really good the pro home
Cooks guy you ever seen that dude uh-uh
he's pretty tired but he takes a
sourdough starter and then he gets some
green onions slices it up and then makes
like a little scallion sourdough pancake
on his cast iron and it's like really
easy not just do a regular scallion
pancake from Asia and it's way better
yeah you do that too but like I don't
want you sourd or [ __ ] to do it the
way it's supposed to be done all right
you [ __ ] bastardizing our [ __ ]
food and you should know yourself that's
[ __ ] yeah you know what I am upset
about this
but it was like something simple you can
make that you don't have to like bake
you could just kind of throw it in a pan
easy you throw it together in like two
minutes dude let me tell you something
people be getting creative with food man
dude that's great yeah air fryers bro
air fries are dug I do like any chef out
there they're sitting on [ __ ] air
fries you're a big you're a [ __ ] big no
I like [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] ball
sack dude yeah
always be [ __ ] on like these ideas
like the air fryer is amazing like it
doesn't fry food we [ __ ] know yeah
all right we [ __ ] know it doesn't fry
[ __ ] food but it's still pretty
[ __ ] good it's great it's it's pretty
goddamn it's easy hey tell me what's
better than air frying some leftover
fries dude oh some leftover Fried
Chicken oh hella good that's a faster
because it's so small and Compact and it
circulates that air perfectly fine don't
[ __ ] talk about my airfryer are
amazing bro like they didn't make
anything good in there and like if you
don't know how to cook and that's
something you want to learn how to do
air fryer is like one of the easiest
things to learn how to fry some bacon
yeah dude easy broccoli you air fry some
broccoli yeah and I'm not trying to
start a [ __ ] restaurant I just want
to eat [ __ ] decent you want something
quick that's the thing people don't
understand too like when they go oh I
made this uh ship from scratch at home
I'm like I don't give a [ __ ] does it
taste good yeah right exactly that took
you eight hours but yeah dude all my
mom's homemade stuff it's like semi-home
made right so when she's doing like
these broth or something she finds like
a quick little work around that's how
most people cook at home yeah most
people aren't like getting the sourdough
start making their fresh bread growing
you know having chickens and getting the
eggs from the [ __ ] chicken vagina is
that what we call it me as if we took a
pasta making class for Valentine's Day
this year and I was like we took the
class and I was like making pasta is
really it is really easy but you're like
oh dude I'm oh I'm not gonna buy a store
made pasta ever yeah I'm not gonna do
this and then I bought the [ __ ]
attachment the pasta maker made it one
time and I was like yeah your boy's good
yeah it's too
check this out when you start having
kids you have a kid you be making hand
making pasta for this child no I don't
know what the [ __ ] it is they go noodle
yeah I love it they're gonna throw them
maybe they probably won't eat it because
it doesn't look like the [ __ ] they
normally get yeah like I did all this
[ __ ] work for you yeah I love
watching this like one Italian dude
where he he actually likes dry pasta he
goes the dry he's like a chef in Italy
he goes no like dry pasta is used for
certain things because it absorbs uh the
pasta sauce better you don't use you
know fresh pasta for [ __ ] everything
yeah like he goes I like a spaghetti
and then you do this all right don't
talk about it easy
I like how the definite what you started
with was what in the message and you got
that from him saying that that's right
so what he's saying is you don't talk
about a disc that's how you translate it
I love Italian people because they're so
hardcore about their [ __ ] food like
if you [ __ ] up one little thing you
don't call that the carbonara you put a
cream in a carbonara and no you use the
starchy water it's already carbonated
that is so [ __ ] mad dude yeah but
sometimes I [ __ ] with Italian-American
food though it's very yeah I like it
yeah just like the same way we like
Chinese chicken parmesan you know what I
mean dude did you guys ever see that
video of those Asian kids [ __ ] on
Panda Express yeah they're losers
but their parents were like these older
Asians are like this is pretty [ __ ]
good like this is not authentic Chinese
no Chinese person would eat this and it
cuts to an old Asian person one I like
this a lot I like this a lot [ __ ]
pulling the towel on it dude it's just
like yeah people in China would eat this
yeah this is great food snobs are
annoying dude especially when it comes
to like
what's traditional and what's like super
like when they're super like when they
die on that Hill too much it's like all
right dude get over it yeah please stop
it see that's the thing too like so
there's this uh one guy that got [ __ ]
mad at me because I made this video
because he was he's he's a guy that just
he like makes his own food and he stuffs
his face with it he's really [ __ ]
hideous but this guy you just hit him
well he could he smacks his mouth I
don't really know who he is but then his
videos started popping up on my thing
and he made a Korean dish and it wasn't
anywhere near what it's supposed to be
right and this guy got mad at me right
and so people some of his fans came
after me too they're like he didn't say
it was authentic I was like I didn't say
he said it was authentic I said his
recipe was trash and I also said that's
fair game because you put the recipe out
you have a responsibility of like
letting people know that this is a it's
not a Korean dish you didn't do that I
was like he's Vietnamese so I'm like if
I took bones and I threw it in water I
said this is fur you Vietnamese people
would throw a fit about it right you
would be upset like that's not [ __ ]
[ __ ] but you did the same thing for my
dish and I'm just like dude this just
[ __ ] trash like all you have to do is
Google a recipe and then just do it that
way yeah and then their response was
like well he's doing his own way I was
like that's 100 fine even if you put out
the disclaimer but the fact is that
you're saying that this is delicious and
this is a version of this Korean dish
and it's not it's just not right so it's
like if I did this with American food
and I said oh look at this delicious hot
dog and it was a hamburger right I was
like what are you talking about it's a
bun and meat it's a it's a hot dog yeah
it's a hamburger isn't it it's like no
people American people like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about and it's the
same equivalent of what he was doing
sure I'm not making a big fuss about it
I'm just saying that this your recipe
was trash but if I if I say that that's
fair game
he writes to me goes I was wondering and
I just saw this not that long ago
because I was going through all DMS kind
of clearing out my DMs and stuff I was
like oh who is this guy he seems mad at
me and I'm like oh that's the guy that I
said in like the recipe and he writes he
goes you're a [ __ ] clown I can't
believe like you're mad at me about this
I was like I just did a video guy I like
it yeah and that's the thing about
creators too it's like you know if you
create stuff you put it out there for
people to judge I'm allowed to have an
opinion on it just like you have an
opinion on my stuff I don't hate you you
ugly [ __ ] also too if you want to come
get it at any time you can come get it
by the way I actually know where he
lives you know where he lives is that
the really big food YouTuber who just
like makes a bunch of food in his in his
house and like I think so I don't know I
don't know a lot of his videos I just
know he chews his lips when he smacks
but he like he just sits he goes oh oh
my God it's so good I'm like bro all
right I'm done with this yes and he
might as well be a really nice person
but listen if you want to fight we can
get it going okay
no I mean fight with words fight with
recipes ooh recipes
I would cook this [ __ ] dude
you guys gotta both cook that dish now
yeah what was the dish he [ __ ] sees
his [ __ ] with uh tears because he's a
little [ __ ] so
he might have an edge on boy I'm just
kidding actually I don't know he's
probably really nice dude yeah but we're
just having fun we're just having fun
I'm just having fun dude I'll kiss you
on your [ __ ] delicious yes
give it a rating because the grease off
your lips is disgusting like food let's
go
shots were fired but it's so weird I was
like why are you upset it's like you
know I create content too and I just be
roasting people and he's like well you
you know this is well why are you so mad
I'm not mad at you I just made a video
and I said your [ __ ] recipe was weird
I didn't like it that's all I think it's
just like you said it's just because
you're putting your thing out it's like
your baby right like anything content
but you have to make that differentiate
that you have to on your own be like if
I put something out people can talk [ __ ]
about this and that's their right and
you have to be okay with that you know
yeah like so it's like if that [ __ ]
looks like ass it looks like ass to me
you know yeah and also I'm Korean I
could talk about my own culture and food
like if you bastardize it and you made
it all weird and you said it was a
recipe for a dish that it really wasn't
yeah I'm allowed to say that [ __ ] like I
said like if I made a [ __ ] Vietnamese
dish and I [ __ ] up the recipe and
you're like that's not what it is I'm
like [ __ ] really then what did I do
wrong yeah but he takes it as well I'm
an authority on food well if you're an
authority on food then do a better job
you [ __ ] wow
Jitsu Academy if you want to come and
get it you can get it any [ __ ]
Tuesday 10 a.m he wants to fight people
no this will these guys put me in the
threads that you should find Salt poppy
that will beat my ass it's all Bobby's
dope I've never I don't know who that is
so he's he's a Filipino guy that goes
like this dog he makes me laugh you know
what he makes me laugh even in the
boxing match he stays in character
people don't know this but he's been
boxing since he was a kid in the
Philippines oh [ __ ] no wonder he's so
sick dude he's [ __ ] sick but they
[ __ ] underestimated because how he
looks like yeah don't [ __ ] with that kid
that fool will [ __ ] put your lights
out and look what happened 20 seconds
into the first round his last fight the
lights out he's a big boy too is he
stays right in the pocket [ __ ]
positioning is perfect for that left
cross pink knock them out
damn is that his only fight or is he
fought uh his second Pro fight I'm gonna
let this dude dude this kid is [ __ ]
slick with it and his first fight fat as
[ __ ] next fight lost more weight and
he's still going down so he's trying to
get to like his Peak optimal level of
Fitness sure I'm his biggest [ __ ] fan
isn't that crazy how like so find the
guy dude yeah knock him the [ __ ] out
isn't that crazy to see that like these
YouTube guys or like these social media
influencer dudes are really making
boxing a serious thing in their world
like I'm sure the checks are pretty big
for these dudes yeah they're gonna be
decent like they're doing a regular like
first uh First Time pro Fighters sure I
mean at least like 50 or maybe even like
25k which yeah two people would be
that's not a lot but for a first time
Pro fight that's pretty that's a fat
[ __ ] that's great yeah that's amazing
let's say he got 50k he got basically he
got 50k for 20 seconds
I mean even when Jake Paul's been able
to accomplish is [ __ ] bananas yeah
insane dude Floyd Mayweather throughout
the whole fight I was like I can't
believe that was Logan Paul yeah and
you're a racist Jake Paul um that's
impressive too the fact that he got to
find Mayweather all the guys that he was
fighting was like I can't believe he's
never seen Silva yeah the thing about
Jacob the one person I actually don't
care to watch box is actually Jake Paul
now the reason why is because he has now
elevated himself where he could fight
better competitors right and so now the
freak Show's done for me I'm done like I
don't not because I have anything
against him it's like the the novelty as
the war officer watching these other
YouTubers who have just started and
they're taking it and watching them get
better incrementally and finding people
at their level is way more exciting
because the exchanges are just better
yeah like Jake Paul cherry picking 50
year old men even if they're Pro
Fighters or whatever whatnot the freak
Show's done like I'm done watching it
sure so that's what I guarantee you
that's why he couldn't sell uh he
couldn't sell his last fight there was
the ticket sales were [ __ ] that was the
final I wanted to see them
his dad was like an OG boxer I fought
like Lennox Lewis or some [ __ ] like
George foreign
story short about that he was brought in
to be Jake's sparring partner right so
Rahman Jr is he started off as a light
heavyweight or a cruiserweight or
something like that but now he's a
heavyweight big big dude so the the
thing that they told him was like don't
put his lights out we're fighting just
make sure that you just uh don't leave
your jab just give him some work and so
he's just giving him light work or
whatever and you see like the the clips
of this he's giving him light work but
he's really rocking the [ __ ] out of Jake
and Jake hits him with a few hard
overhands and you just see Rockman eat
it he goes good [ __ ] after the fight's
over Jake gets on the [ __ ] you know
the corner of the ring and starts going
I'm a champ I'm a champ that gets on
rockman's nerve because he's like yo I'm
just giving you light work and you're
getting in my face about this [ __ ] so he
has a problem with him yeah and so but
Jake only put up the thing of him like
throwing that hard cross on him or
whatever and they're often being really
emotional so they set up this fight
because Tommy uh Tommy Fury Tommy Fury
is out
Jake lo and behold decides to put all
these like little contract stipulations
that nobody knew about like a weight
cutting one that was really gonna [ __ ]
him over like really [ __ ] Motors but
and you know people who don't watch
Boxing they don't understand that they
go well he's a professional he should
have just made weight it was impossible
for him to no but even then he went damn
near close to it because he what the
claws was is that he and mistake me uh
like correct me if I'm mistaken but it
was
he had to be way under his normal
fighting weight because I think he was
like 210 215 or something that's where
he usually fights at the fight was like
supposed to be like 190 or something
or like one it was like 200 and he came
in on the day of at 205.5 which was
pretty damn close and then they said you
can't rehydrate
on the next day at all so you have to
stay at that weight that's insane for
the day of the fight so that means you
have to he has to spend a whole 24 hours
being in a dehydrated State that's
insane to be able to fight him and how
and Jake Paul naturally is around the
same way right 200 190 or something and
also Jake Paul is always [ __ ] guys that
he's way bigger than like literally 30
40 pounds heavier than this so exactly
but people don't put they go well he's
well rockman's a professional it's like
understand that Rahman took the fight
because he didn't care about the purse
because the original stipulation was
like Hey if you're over this weight
um you for every pound that you're over
if we take away X percentage of your
purse so by the time he weighed in he
was gonna make no money off this at most
twenty five hundred dollars but Romans I
don't give a [ __ ] I want to [ __ ] him up
yeah and so Jake's he's very he made it
seem as if it's like rockman's fault but
he kind of set it up to fail so he
doesn't have to box him got it and so
ticket sales were terrible he made it
seem like it was rockman's fault but
anybody who watches boxing who
understands that oh he this is a trap I
can't believe the no hydration Clause
that's insane
a lot of these new boxing fans they
don't watch Boxing they don't understand
anything exactly so they go oh rockman's
a [ __ ] I was like no no no no no that's
not how this [ __ ] works out but he's
gonna have his work cut out for him
finding Andy yeah but knowing his
[ __ ] luck he might knock out anything
he might he might hey ever since that
was 47. yeah he's old yeah
and also how he looked against Chavez Jr
dude exactly it looked good but he's I
mean he is older though you never know
yeah and then I think Jake Paul's gonna
have a uh the reason why he's gonna be
really Troublesome from [ __ ] Anderson
tells a tricky ass Southpaw dude he's
tricky as [ __ ] because he knows he's
seen it all Anderson in the boxing and
stand up he's seen it all you know like
he he knows what to expect but ah man I
don't know you just never know when you
never know Tyrone Woodley I could not
believe I couldn't believe it I still
think that I can't believe it is
every time I'm like this is it can't be
real dude it's so funny like after that
fight happened like Tyler like it's no
love on his Instagram anymore everybody
lost hella respect for him which is so
crazy and I remember him being like
don't you know this thing kind of
tarnish my legacy like yeah it a hundred
percent did it was excuse Kyle Woodley
fan after that [ __ ] let me feel yes I
was man you know why I was because he
slept Josh koschek like a [ __ ]
biggest title Woodly fan yeah but then
how about the Damian Meyer fight were
you a big fan of them after that one
yeah
me too
the costume was nice though that [ __ ]
was sweet coffee was so [ __ ] annoying
yeah dude everybody
so much [ __ ] for somebody that did
nothing in the UFC the blanket is what
they used to call the blanket it was a
lamprey I [ __ ] hated him anyways guys
shout out Josh costumes this is for you
Baby dedicated to you if you want to
come on this podcast we cannot scrap any
time he would wrestle me through the
floor and destroy me yeah I remember
watching him on the old he's a fighter
and was like no he's not that bad that's
what I thought like as a person yeah
yeah but I was also like 19. and well
you're a terrible judge of character
yeah yeah there it is you're horrible
you can find Nick at Nick the ear
and you can find Patrick at
patrick.t.right to his brain every
Sunday at 12 p.m and by the way this
this uh Jake Paul talk you probably
because I don't know when this shit's
gonna come out it's probably already be
viewing or some [ __ ] I don't know these
are nice TVs yeah these are real TVs you
guys this is not a [ __ ] idiot we'll
see you all next time this is a real ass
Studio
now
[Music]